the Joe Rogan experience you know
Whitney come you just do you know
Whitney I do a little bit not well do I
like her
ask her about the dm's that she chose
him to us it's really get a book I said
you should write a book about dick pics
that people send you because it's not
not a dozen it's doesn't really dozens
man is she's always got like weird dicks
coming her way to like curvy when a
group text she'll show us the dicks and
like what the [ __ ]
Wow weird weird hook Dixon yeah do they
like does she like it now
yeah see this is one it's just guys just
send pictures they do it to every girl
look there is probably a [ __ ]
gigantic population of creepy dudes out
there yeah dick pics well here's another
one I was hooking up with his girl years
ago I met in Arizona and she was like
send me a dick pic I was like alright
sent to the dick pic eight five I will
say five years goes by I get a tweet hey
is this mark your dick it's added me and
it was it was my sheets my shoes were in
it my desk was in the background and I
was like that's not mine and I was like
it spooked me so she sent you that or
someone else to some random guy like
Minnesota she's this you're dizzy text
it to some guy and I just didn't know
for Combe put it on Twitter
I gave it a favorite and I moved on
you're not interesting out Twitter let's
just show dicks to Twitter lets you show
hardcore porn hardcore porn hardcore
porn which is fun sometimes you in the
airport like a [ __ ]
it's crazy I'll look at this for a
minute yeah they I mean you can ask
[ __ ] coming everyone everything you
name it baby isn't that weird that meets
a gigantic platform to into well
hardcore porn Instagram does not know
you can't show nipple oh wow you can't
show anything girls get kicked off an
Instagram for having like transparent
shirts oh really yeah nipple isn't it
amazing when you see how many beautiful
sexy stunning women are on Instagram you
could go through for our we write our
prey our best resource you talk about
oil and all this [ __ ] I think the hot
women in America it's up there it's
pretty good it's better so there's a lot
of photoshop out there
writing about these ladies doing cartoon
work on their pictures killed my dream
man in the dream also it's weird this is
some guy's daughter and some mom's
daughter no yep that's but then she hits
24 she's on her own I guess so look
whatever age you nervously see a picture
yeah you have to be but I'm also look I
think girls like boys and boys like
girls I want everybody to be happy you
know yeah I would hope that they are
this case too
I would hope that you know they could
find someone who's nice to them and I
would hope that you know yeah they won't
don't get bullshitted but I mean
remember you you were a [ __ ] poon
hound back in the 40s you know you know
you know what it's like Cosby radio
though that's true imagine if you live
in like like legitimately living like a
thousand years ago like what they
probably didn't even understand what how
you got pregnant you know a diseases
killed you you got syphilis everybody
died your hair fell out your nose rotted
off your face yeah they would have crazy
diseases and no cure that's probably why
the Bible steps in you know it's like I
don't eat pork pork skill anybody let's
say no need pork on Friday or whatever
it is abstinence too they're trying to
preserve you right venereal diseases
right yeah and that's why being a virgin
was so good you know if you're not you
get thrown in the volcano yeah yeah I
was reading this book about the Wild
West and they're talking about all the
people that are get that had syphilis
mm-hm just they just all went to [ __ ]
houses and they're right that's sick and
while we're so lucky to be alive in this
time we're we're gonna yelled it on
Twitter those guys had to ride a horse
without a saddle
[Applause]